Wear blue collar wives.
Of course. I am always finding things in the wash.
Wear blue collar wives. Of course.
I'm always having to mop the floors because of dirt.
Wear blue collar wives.
I'm gonna have a hot meal ready
for him when he comes home.
Wear blue collar wives.
If I don't pack him lunch,
he's gonna eat gas station food or nothing at all.
Wear blue collar wives. Of course.
Half my lunch containers are in his car.
Wear blue collar wives.
It's not a car ride if he's
not pointing out what things he's worked on.
In our town,
we're blue collar wise.
Our dates look like going to Lowe's.
While he goes to the tool section,
I go to the garden section.
We're blue collar wise.
I have a long list of projects for him to do
because he's skilled enough to do them.
We're blue collar wise.
Of course. My husband wears this color to work.